les écouteurs les plus sexy du moment
sont de retour ce sont les nothing here
tout vous avez un design qui est super
beau super atypique vous pouvez en plus
c'est faire tourner facilement dans
votre main et ça c'est cool c'est la
marque nothing qui vient de sortir c'est
nouveau here tout avec vraiment ce côté
transparent qui est super beau que ce
soit au niveau de l'étui mais également
au niveau des écouteurs vous avez une
petite couleur soit rouge soit blanc
pour savoir si c'est gauche ou si c'est
droit 3 tailles d'embout la tenue juste
topissime vous avez plus de la réduction
de bruit active un nouveau codec trois
micros une application qu'on peut venir
utiliser dans le nothing phone ou dans
n'importe quel smartphone Android ou iOS
qui vous donnera accès à un équaliseur
pour venir paramétrer votre son plus
aiguë plus grave médium vous avez
également un profil personnalisé au
niveau de votre audition avec un petit
test très rapide qui vous permet de
venir compenser les défauts de votre
oreille et que bon les sur un produit un
peu geek vous avez plein de
fonctionnalités plein de paramètres
directement dans votre application et
contrairement à la génération précédente
la commande tactile vient évoluer en
fait c'est un petit pincement que vous
avez sur le côté play pause morceau
suivant morceau précédent alors vous
dites moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous aimez ce
design ok moi ça bien évidemment en bas
dans les commentaires